guys before the video starts please help
me to reach my target for the winter
appeal for palestine and gaza people are
literally freezing we would never live
in those conditions help me reach my
target to give them some warmth
[Music]
you can build a habit with the quran buy
seven day free trial bonuses no credit
card details required at all and you
decide for yourself is it overrated or
is it underrated go to the link in the
description box below on sister's
android and ios the link is there
download it and see what time it is
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys will inshallah brothers
and sisters in pakistan a atrocious a
disgusting act
was taken place towards
an
individual a sri lankan individual who's
living in that country residing that
country he was killed brutally killed
and set on fire
now
anyone in the muslim community will
condemn this action anybody now you're
going to ask me the question
well hold on a second bob
mate are you not the same guy who said
we are proud of that
yes and i'm still proud of that
the thing is the issue is not that i'm
contradicting myself or i'm bipolar it's
just that you're stupid you're stupid
that's the issue let me tell you why
you're stupid
like hijab says come here let me slap
you you know who you are apush yeah you
know who you are and i'm gonna debunk
you let me tell you guys very clearly
this goes to anybody who's doing videos
again this is what islam teaches yeah i
would debate you guys on this challenge
yeah not debate online in your bedroom
or you know let me wear uh you know
these um vr virtual reality let's have a
debate in metaverse you know or let's
get into a fight you know imagine
challenging someone to a fight and they
said oh i'm gonna
fight you in the meta verse yeah it's a
coward just want to come and debate i
did an open challenge i told him to come
first he said oh no i don't want to come
et cetera i prefer behind my bedroom
sitting in my bedroom you know etc etc
then he said oh no i will come by no
audience all excuses yeah even in this
topic i'll debate you why let me tell
you something what islam tells us when
it comes to the capital punishment of
apostates is not the same as a man an
individual who is being accused who is
being accused
and it could even be a personal vendetta
it can be that an individual has a
personal vendetta against this person
and lies about him and then people come
together and lynch him and kill him now
the thing is is this new
because the thing is a couple of months
ago cosmic skeptic that little boy
he did the same thing he came out with
you know islam and this you know capital
punishments
and he makes it seem as if islam and
muslims we're the only individuals that
can't deal with freedom of speech or
someone criticizing our religion and i
asked him very clearly i actually
challenged him to a debate on this very
topic i challenged him and i said look
do you have any evidence
any data any survey that is done that
shows you that
individuals went to different
communities the jewish community the
black community the white community the
hispanic community all communities and
they insulted them
none of the communities be it religious
jewish christian hindu muslim all of
them nobody responded violently except
the muslims do you have this kind of
study survey data no you don't so the
point i'm trying to make here is very
clear in islam you are not allowed to go
and if somebody for example apostated
you are not allowed to go and take money
into your own hand this is not from
islam
this is not there are judges and laws
and procedures in place for a reason
so the way these individuals these
scumbags are making it out to be is as
if islam allows in an islamic country
that if somebody comes and says
statements of disbelief or whatever it
may be that they will be killed no
because we know in spain like if you
read the books of martyrs of cordoba
this issue actually happened when the
christian a group of christians most of
the christians lived in peace with the
muslims when they came there was a group
of individuals like they were the group
that you have today like isis yeah they
came together and they started to insult
the prophet yeah when this happened when
you read the book matters of cordoba
none of those um instances if you read
it tell you that these individuals were
lynched they were taken to court and in
the court they were given the capital
punishment it didn't work in a way where
opposite where you go and lynch now
let's check some stats and let's see
um some news and let's see if this is
new to islam yeah so this is one of the
things that i found in russia lynch mob
brutally raped a russian man with an
iron rod
and batted him to death after a children
joked that he touched them
he was lynched
now let's go to india beaten and
humiliated by the hindu mobs for being a
muslim in india we know the pandemic in
india yeah starting with officials at
the top yeah the government that's
ruling yeah bjp whatever the hell
they're called what they are doing to
the muslims just for being muslim or
saying chant our god's name yeah these
filthy scumbag mushriks yeah what
they're doing to the believers yeah
let's let's carry on
um and what they did
to this man his name is muhammad zubair
yeah he was beaten by a hindu mob in one
of the most shocking images from a week
of violence in delhi yeah he was beaten
why because of his face his faith yeah
um again
inside delhi beaten lynched and burnt
alive
yeah this has happened in india towards
muslims violence in india's capital has
left more than 40 dead and hundreds
injured after a hindu nationalist
rampage stopped by the rhetoric of the
narendra modi may allah destroy him
populist government yeah brazil now in
brazil this is a pandemic by the way
it's it's a phenomena what's the
phenomenon brazil grapples with lynch
mob epidemic and they say a group a good
criminal is a dead criminal so what's
happened in brazil is crime rates are so
high that the people have taken the
matters the law into their own hands and
they are lynching these people who are
committing these um
acts theft or whatever it may be
another one a mayan mob kills two baby
steelers a japanese tourist and a
golden bus driver were killed in a rural
indian market after being attacked by a
mob of about 500 angry villagers who
thought the victims were there to steal
the children
another one this was maybe a um
60 70 years ago japanese lynch in us
rome hears italian diplomats returning
from america say shocking treatment was
meted out assert assert mobs attacked
demi correspondent declared beaten by
new york police at his home
here yeah i don't know what kind of
english this is but anyways yeah so they
were beaten again 150 years ago a mob
attacked lost
a mob attacked los angeles chinese
community yeah and there was people that
were killed
next one now this is from england yeah
this was a man his first name his
surname is wooden if i'm not mistaken he
was a black man yeah and there was
racism that was going on um in um those
days in america i'll read that for you
so what it was a 24 year old black sea
man who was caught up in a riot in
liverpool in june 1919 black black men
had lost their jobs after no so black
men had lost their jobs after white men
refused to work with them and a
caribbean man had been stabbed by two
white men fights followed and the police
were bursting into the into the homes of
black people walton was caught up in
this and the white mob threw him into
king's dock as he tried to swim and get
out of the dock he was pelted with
bricks until he sank and died it was it
was right edo lodge a public lynching
yeah now the list goes on why am i
mentioning these things for because it
goes back to my point which cosmic
skeptic took the video down yeah he went
quiet and you know why he took his video
down yeah you laugh at this apparently
his life was in danger he was being
threatened not because he took the video
down because he had no
argument he had no foundation then he
knew he would be absolutely smashed on
the topic when i challenged him for a
debate not because of that he says that
my life is in danger so cliche yeah
anybody that gets their facts wrong and
are debunked for some reason
the very person the very person who has
done videos mocking the um what the
woman where yeah installing the prophet
muhammed his life wasn't in danger then
but now his life got in danger it looks
like individuals who spew lies and
nonsenses when they are refuted their
lives become in danger yeah i think they
like their lives are intellectually
in danger that's the issue here
the point is very clear and i'm going to
end on this note
what i'm trying to say is the following
what data what survey do you have
that you think that the muslims what
they did to this man was filthy
disgusting and the islamic law does not
call for this
yes capital punishment applies and i've
said it before i'm proud of that
i am proud of that how does that
contradict it's a contra distinction
learn the difference it doesn't
contradict one is individuals taking the
matters in their own hand this could be
a lie against this individual it can be
a person of vendetta that is not the
same as a
as the islamic law a legitimate islamic
law having in place a capital punishment
it is two separate things so you cannot
equate that equate this to islam and i
would challenge you to a debate face to
face with audience you coward to come
and debate me on this topic yeah don't
run away like cosmic skeptic yeah so my
point again
go to any nation and i'm going to end on
this go to any nation if i went to a
bible belt in america where the bible
believes if i went to these hillbillies
and i said you know your bible yeah
here's the middle finger to your bible
yeah what do you think they're going to
do to him they're going to say you know
what you know you have a right to your
freedom of speech you know like one
philosopher said what was his name
what's his name the philosopher i
despise what you say by
walter walter volta
like a voltage
yeah
yeah vote like voltaire said i despise
what you say but i'll defend you to
death you're right to see it no he's
going to take his he'll be the gun out
and shoot me he's going to kill me like
that movie um die hard the guy goes into
the black community with the n-word the
guy comes and says brother you know
you're about to get killed yeah this is
a normal psychological reaction in any
community and this law of blasphemy
it's it's it applies everywhere just
because something for example go to
front go to a nationalist front area in
in france and insult the flag i dare you
you will get lynched you will get beaten
why is it made as if islam has this you
know we are the only ones that cannot
deal with criticism yeah blasphemy laws
apply in different places in different
ways and myself if i went to a white
nationalist area you know what forget
this forget this nonsense yeah if you
notice this me and muhammad went to a
tommy robinson freedom of speech event
brother look at the irony the freedom of
speech event we went there and we was
nearly killed
so the point the question that we need
to ask is why was we lynched why did
they tell tommy robinson if alidawah
comes up and speaks he won't come back
down
why did they say that what happened to
freedom of speech you lying cowards
so my point in the nature is this i
would debate any of these cowards yeah
face to face face to face on this topic
that islam is the only religion that is
the ones that um that we are the ones
that we can't deal with
criticism this is absolutely a lie
brothers and sisters until next time
assalamu alaikum
send this to the relevant possibilities
please goodbye